I just want you to remember in terms of
integration right we use the integration
we encountered the idea to solve a
particular kind of problem what kind of
problem was it it was area right where
are my colors we learned that if you
take a function right if you take a
function and you want you to consider
the area beneath it yeah you can
consider it as a whole bunch of really
really thin vertical rectangles right
and so you add these things up right you
add them up so for example in this case
if I just said we know maybe this is y
equals x squared okay the way I would
form this integral is I would say okay
I'm sorry for this area is you get your
upper lower bounds and then you would
say integrate Y with respect to X right
so that would be x squared DX
you get executed on three you'd evaluate
at the boundaries and so on does that
make sense now one of the reasons why I
write Y instead of x squared is to help
you remember that these two things here
are the height and width of a rectangle
right each of these is DX Y there's that
infinitesimally thing with and they're
why hi right and the Y keeps on changing
so you have a whole bunch of different
rectangles so far so good now that was
one thing we could do you could add up
other things as well though you don't
have to have rectangles that are up
right you could have rectangles like
this then sideways yeah now I would form
a different integral to find this area
what would i sorry
what would I fall I wouldn't say yes
okay now I'm going to need yeah I can
put that video I've got my X's okay now
what is X represent in this case it's
these whips right and the widths are all
changing yes X and the dy is the height
okay and that's that little infant
and you're gonna need some boundaries as
well I'm rather than writing a and B
because they're usually reserved for a
horizontal thing the battery sure gonna
be any vertical boundaries right there
y-coordinates so maybe this value and
this value so maybe just for convenience
sake we'll call him see it so we could
form integrals like that and we said
look you know what you don't have to
just to be limited through rectangles
right I said go back to the humble
circle right and the weak we know
clearly well the formula for the area of
a circle and the formula for the
circumference of a circle right
and we said those are connected by
saying if you add up a whole bunch of
circumference --is right and how would I
do that
I would say the area equals each
circumference is 2 pi odd do you
remember that what's the width of each
one it's going to be team R that's the
thing that's changing the radius each
time the smallest circle has a radius 0
the biggest one is a reason ah and off
you go right so you can do rectangle
standing-up rectangle sideways
circumference is right you can add up
you can integrate anything you like
which is what leads us to this graph
okay now we're going to integrate
something completely different in fact
we're even going to be in different
dimension but to help you understand
what's going on and they should take
this graph and we'll just call it you
know y equals any old function of X I
want to think about well if I take this
and get an area underneath this curve so
for example let's have a boundary a
and I already know what kind of integral
I can form in order to find this area
underneath the curve that's fine okay
but I'm interested in doing something a
little more interesting I'm interested
in taking this area the one that I just
described and rotating it around an axis
like say the x-axis now this isn't
really conceptually I'm going to draw it
here I want you to work with me and then
I'm going to show you what this looks
like I'm gonna animate it for you okay
but it's really important that you do
this work first so that your brain goes
through the process okay I'll try and
justify that more in a second I want you
to imagine like a potter's wheel okay if
you imagine the potter's wheel spinning
around and around like this okay and
you're kind of like holding your hands
in so that you get this kind of shape
all right what are you going to get is a
shape looks just like this reflected
downwards right so for example you go
the same distance there and the same
distance you're going to get that shape
on the other side right because remember
it's going round and round around came
the same shape on both sides but because
it's going around in a second you get a
round shape okay so you get this
now this is not an area like this okay
this is a 3d shape it's a solid right
like just like if you had a potter's
wheel and you were you know tada here's
my thing it's an actual physical 3d
shape okay because it's a solid that's
formed by rotating this thing around
right by revolving it around an axis we
call this kind of shape a solid of
revolution solids and we are no longer
finding an area we are going to find the
volume of this thing okay so the
question then becomes well how do I find
the bold move you bought this shape the
answer is in exactly the same way that
we looked at all of these shapes
you took one pot you added up a whole
bunch of them you is degrading them all
together so the question is what kinds
of parts can we divide this up into and
then combine this together to get this
shape yeah okay very good if I went
across here right with a knife and
sliced it across this way right I'm kind
of like cutting up salami what I would
get is a whole bunch of slices better
all circular every single one okay so
I'm going to roll one in the middle and
we're going to use it as an example take
a spot like here right okay
now every time I slice across I'm going
to get this kind of circular shape like
that
now just like we had here rectangles
that were kind of like infinitesimally
thin or rectangles that were
consistently high okay I'm going to
think of this this whole thing's meant
to be evolved you right so like that
thing there I want to consider it as a
tiny infinitesimally thin cylinder okay
so give it for me
a tiny bit of width just like those guys
are meant to have you know each of these
is actually even testily wide okay so
I'm going to draw this with a little bit
of width like so okay
so it's like a little disc if you like
now one of the dudes I'm gonna take that
disc and I'm gonna put it off on the
side yeah so I can consider it just on
this bearing so this is like a little
slice of my solid of revolution now what
do I know about it well just like we
said it's infinitesimally thin just like
our original integrals with
infinitesimally thin so I'm gonna call
that with just like I've given it
already the name already and would call
that DX okay that's my infant asleep in
which there it's a cylinder so this
width here is kind of like the height of
the cylinder you're kind of looking at
it sideways right what other dimension
do I need to know the volume of this
cylinder
I need its radius don't I that radius is
this height here okay now that idea is
whatever this y-value is to see that
like that tells you how tall how wide
this song this cylindrical disc is going
to get I already have a name for this
it's the same thing I had over here
right this radius is the same as this
length right up here the height of those
into a luminaire so this is really just
what I know the radius I know the height
of the cylinder what's the volume of
this particular cylinder here pi times
the radius square which is 1
times the height which is dance that is
and just to put their back this is the
equipment of PI R squared H you'll see
that that's just the volume of a
cylinder okay but that's just one of
them I don't want just one of them
I want all of them all together okay
and that's exactly what integration does
it's like I don't just want this one so
in order to get the total volume so this
is just of one slice the total volume is
all of those slices add it together
right and I really have created I've
gone to great lengths to create the
notation and the language to describe
that right
I want the integral right from one
boundary to the other one A to B of all
these guys all these cylinders PI Y
squared DX this will give me the volume
of this weird rotated shape yes you mean
the area okay I'm going to let you ever
think about why that would have serious
troubles okay what we're considering is
just that area right and then thinking
about this circumference here okay it's
problematic to say the least
how would you actually try the numbers
crunching the numbers and see why it
doesn't work
there's a reason why we chose to divide
it into these cylindrical kinds of
shapes okay partly because I get
cylinders of this kind everywhere no
matter where I cut okay which is why I
can add up a whole bunch of them in
series